quisiera preguntarle en primer lugar
Cuál es el impacto de la tragedia en los
niños Cuántos Y cómo calculan que se han
visto afectados
bueno el impacto es devastador
mencionabais antes con mucha Claridad
que los niños son probablemente junto a
las personas ancianas no nos olvidemos
de ellos los que menos recursos y menos
capacidad tienen para enfrentar
cualquier tipo de desgracia dependen más
de la ayuda de terceros nosotros tenemos
una preocupación enorme por lo que está
sucediendo en Turquía pero
comparativamente mayor por lo que está
sucediendo en Siria Donde ha habido 12
años de guerra civil y la situación era
mucho más precaria y mucho más delicada
nosotros estamos trabajando con una
cifra de atención en los próximos meses
de cerca de 700.000 niños son muchos más
pero nosotros nos hemos fijado como
compromiso llegar hasta 700.000 niños la
mayor parte de ellos casi medio millón
en Siria el resto en Turquía Vicente
cuéntenos cómo trabaja la ong set de
chile en esta tragedia como usted bien
aclarada no los niños y las personas
adultas son uno de los sectores más
vulnerables de la población requieren
respuestas específicas diferenciadas
Sí evidentemente nosotros respondiendo
la primera parte de su pregunta nosotros
teníamos yo que iba a decir la desgracia
de llevar junto a otras organizaciones
de referencia muchos años trabajando en
el sur del sur de Turquía y en el norte
de Siria Pues por la guerra civil de
Siria no 12 años son muchos años y
teníamos oficinas hemos perdido
compañeros hemos perdido oficinas y
teníamos ya equipos tenemos equipos que
ellos mismos han sido afectados y ellos
mismos se han puesto a trabajar junto a
familiares y amigos en la primera en la
primera respuesta en lo que respecta una
atención de financiada efectivamente O
sea hay hospitales ahora mismo que son
solamente atención pediátrica los niños
tienen unas necesidades médicas
especiales y en nuestro caso tenemos una
especialidad muy particular en lo que
llamamos protección a la infancia los
primeros auxilios psicológicos Es cierto
que los niños nos los contamos todos a
nosotros mismos con mucha facilidad los
niños se recuperan muy rápido tiene
mucha capacidad de adaptación pero a un
precio entonces lo que tratamos de hacer
es proteger a estos niños y que de
alguna manera recuperen esta capacidad
de volver a ser niños y en ese espacio
que creamos de confianza de juego se
hace una evaluación psicológica y se
derivan a servicios psicológicos Pues
que especializados en atender en atender
trauma pero en estos momentos falta de
todo o sea hay millones de personas que
han perdido las casas que han perdido
sus medios de vida que lo han perdido
todo entonces estamos hablando de una
operación que va desde salvar vidas
hasta mantener con vida a personas
Durante este invierno que está siendo
terriblemente frío Durante los próximos
meses hablemos ahora de los niños
rescatados no acompañados no que se
encuentran absolutamente solos qué
sucederá con ellos Cuáles son los
procedimientos en estos casos Pues yo
creo que Bueno mira curiosamente en
estos momentos hay uno habla de
solidaridad a la que hay que agradecer
pero hay que recordar a la gente porque
se nos hacen regularmente esta pregunta
que las por ejemplo las adopciones
internacionales es costumbre
suspenderlas y uno podrá preguntarse
Pero cómo es posible bueno pues es
posible porque y es recomendable Porque
en estos casos se produce una situación
de desprotección extrema y los niños son
particularmente vulnerables cualquier
esquema de trata de tráfico y de
explotación infantil entonces uno de los
grandes trabajos que hay que hacer en
estos momentos o que estaban de
reunificación familiar son niños que
pueden haber sido Salvados derivados
hospitales de campaña o hospitales de
referencia turcos y sirios y están solos
en Turquía la propia administración ha
sido víctima los registros civiles las
mezquitas todos los lugares donde estas
personas se registraban también han sido
víctimas y damnificados por el terremoto
entonces la labor de registro de
identificación de estos niños junto con
organizaciones de referencia aquí la
Cruz Roja Internacional hace un papel
importantísimo es fundamental hay que
protegerlos hay que cuidarlos hay que
guardarlos hay que asistirlos durante
una temporada hasta que se declare
perfectamente Cuál es el mejor interés
del menor y con un tío con un abuelo
entrar en tu sistema de protección Turco
ahora bien en Siria es mucho más
complicado el acceso es mucho más
complicado la administración pública es
casi inexistente ahí el reto va a ser
mayúsculo y mucho más complicado